let f of x is let f of x be equal to
negative 1 over x minus 1 squared select
the correct description of the one-sided
limits of f at x equals 1. and so we can
see we have a bunch of choices where
we're approaching x from the right-hand
side and we're approaching x from the
left hand side and we're trying to
figure out do we get unbounded on either
of those
in the positive posit towards positive
infinity or negative infinity and
there's a couple of ways to tackle it
the most straightforward well let's just
consider each of these separately so we
could think about the limit of f of x as
x approaches 1 from the positive
direction
and
limit
of f of x
as x approaches 1
as x approaches 1 from the left-hand
side this is from the right-hand side
this is from the left-hand side so i'm
just going to make a table and try out
some values as we approach
as we approach one from the different
sides x
f of x
and i'll do the same thing over here
so
we are going to have
our x
and have our f of x and if we approach 1
from the right hand side here that would
be approaching 1 from above so we could
try
1.1 we could try 1.01
now f of 1.1 is negative 1 over 1.1
minus 1
squared so see this denominator here is
going to be 0.1 squared so this is going
to be
this is going to be
0.01
and so this is going to be
negative 100.
so let me just write that down that's
going to be negative 100.
so if we if x is 1.01 well this is going
to be negative one over
1.01 minus 1
squared well in this denominator this is
going to be point
this is the same thing as
0.01 squared which is the same thing as
zero point zero zero zero one one ten
thousandth and so the negative one one
ten thousandth is going to be negative
ten thousand so let's just write that
down
negative
10
000. and so this looks like as we get
closer because notice as i'm going here
i am approaching 1 from the positive
direction i'm getting closer and closer
to 1 from above and i'm going unbounded
towards negative infinity so this looks
like it is negative infinity
now we could do the same thing from the
left hand side i could do 0.9
i could do
0.99
now 0.9 is actually also going to get me
negative 100 because 0.9 minus
1
is going to be
negative 0.1
but then when you square it the negative
goes away so you get .01 and then 1
divided by that is 100 but you have the
negative so this is also negative 100
and if you don't follow those
calculations i'll do it let me do it one
more time just so you see it clearly
there's going to be negative 1
over so now i'm doing x is equal to 0.99
so i'm getting even closer to 1 but i'm
approaching from below from the left
hand side
so this is going to be
0.99
minus 1 squared
well 0.99 minus 1 is
is going to be negative 100 so this is
going to be
negative 0.01
squared well when you square it the
negative goes away and you're left with
one ten thousandth so this is going to
be zero point 0.0001
and so when you evaluate this you get 10
000.
so that or sorry you get negative
10
000. so in either case regardless of
which direction we approach from we are
approaching
negative infinity so
that is this choice right over here now
there's other ways you could have
tackled this if you just look at kind of
the structure of this expression here
the numerator is a constant so that's
clearly always going to be positive
let's ignore this negative for the time
being that negative is out front this
numerator this one is always going to be
positive down here we're taking the at x
equals 1 well this becomes 0 and the
whole expression becomes undefined but
as we approach 1
x minus 1 could be positive or negative
as we see over here but then when we
square it this is going to become
positive as well so the denominator is
going to be positive for any x other
than one so positive divided by positive
is going to be positive but then you
have a negative out front so this thing
is going to be negative for any x other
than one and it's actually not defined
at x equals one and so you could from
that you could deduce well okay then we
can only go to negative infinity there's
actually no way to get positive values
for this function